it's just the start of 2016 and we've
already had our first release delay
scalebound the upcoming Xbox one
exclusive action RPG that lets you fight
alongside a fearsome dragon named Reuben
has been delayed to 2017
an update on scalebound was published on
a blog post on a PlatinumGames website
today proposed says development on the
game is going well and we're really
happy with how it's coming together
scalebound is one of the biggest games
Platinum Games has ever created an epic
adventure filled with exploration and
fantasy gameplay inventive multiplayer
and action-packed battles on an
unbelievable scale all set in a
beautiful and evolving world
it's the game our team has always
dreamed of making it sounds like the
team is undertaking quite the mission
and have chosen to delay the game to
allow for more development time the post
goes on to say in order to deliver on
our ambitious vision and ensure that
scalebound lives up to expectations we
will be launching the game in 2017 this
will give us the time needed to bring to
life all the innovative features and
thrilling gameplay experiences that we
have planned no new precise release date
has been offered but fans have been
excited about the release of scalebound
since its first announcement at e3 in
2014 so this news will surely break a
few dragon hearts fan games have said
they will be sharing more about their
vision for scalebound later this year
giving fans a closer look at the project
and the games world of Draconis so how
does the scalebound delay make you feel
which you prefer to play sooner rather
than later or are you happy to accept
the delay if it makes for a better game
let us know in the comments below
or you can find me on twitter at a
regular dave and pour no scalebound news
stay tuned to games what calm